think they think au ltte thénard
atteinte au cateau et brisé mon
doucement bretagne je suis irlandaise
alors pourquoi je commence mon discours
en maori la langue de la nouvelle
zélande
je vais ce soir vous parler des langues
des langues et des images
je parle surtout des langues minorisées
le td aux maoris la langue maori et puis
l'irlande et la langue gaélique
d'irlande
parce que c'est dans mon expérience dans
les deux cas il s'agit des langues
minorisées dix langues qui après
l'histoire sont maintenant parler de
d'assez peu de personnes mais qui reste
toujours très important pour l'identité
pour la culture
j'ai choisi cette image pour commencer
parce que c'est un petit peu choquant et
et puis elle montre aussi la relation
parfois douloureuses que les gens
peuvent avoir avec une langue qu'ils ne
parlent pas et qui sont censés maîtriser
et c'est souvent le cas dans les
situations de perte de transmission
intergénérationnelle intergénérationnel
où par exemple les parents les grands
parents n'avaient pas transmis leur
langue
au petit et pourquoi l'irlande et la
nouvelle-zélande
ce sont deux pays avec des populations
plus ou moins de la même largeur on peut
dire ça 4 millions 25,6 habitants m
dans les deux pays qui se trouvent
chacun à l'autre hémisphère par rapport
à l'autre j'ai trouvé quand même
quelques quelques parallèles
il y a bien sûr beaucoup de différence
mais pour ce soir je vais parler plutôt
des je vais commencer avec ce qu'ils ont
en commun ce sont des îles ils ont tous
les deux une culture orale très forte
une musique traditionnelle qui est très
présente aussi tous les deux pays ont
connu la colonisation et en justement
comme je disais tout à l'heure des
relations un peu bizarre avec leur
langue minorisée j'aimerais vous poser
une question
avant de commencer dans la partie langue
et la question est la suivante vous
souvenez vous de vos premiers mots ou
des premiers mots de vos petits frères
soeurs vos enfants éventuellement
souvent il s'agit des mots pour mama
papa souvent les premiers mots ce sont
les mots relationnel
nous les êtres humains on est des êtres
relationnel il s'est vraiment dans cette
optique là qu'il faut considérer les
langues
chaque langue est une tentative de
communiqué dé s'exprimer d'aller vers
l'autre on essaie de comprendre l'autre
tout en se rendant quand que sait jamais
tout à fait possible 100% il reste
toujours quelque chose de mystérieux
chez l'autre même si on parle la même
langue
pour illustrer ce propos j'aimerais
vous montrez je viens j'ai plus de mains
je fais comme ça en français on peut
très bien dire je vous ai montré un de
diapos en english the way in english
d'environ 10 au 12 e round
et pourquoi un geste qui est tout à fait
ils nous sont en français en anglais ça
peut être considéré comme offensif et
pourquoi les gestes même sens différent
en anglais en français je veux dire
salut à quelqu'un je peux faire comme ça
mais pas un grec
en grèce il faut plutôt faire comme ça
sinon on risque de ne pas passer pour un
ami plutôt l' inverse
tout ça pour dire que les langues les
gestes les cultures sont différentes
vous le saviez déjà
mais juste pour souligner même
maintenant au 21e siècle dans les pays
développés et nouvelle zélande irlande
il reste quand même les particularités
de culture maintenant je veux vous
montrer
pardon j'ai pas expliqué le dernier
dicton ce sont deux dictons irlandais et
mauri qui parle de l'interdépendance des
gens de l'être humain
là on voit les a ratées mais à nouilles
sautées à eau et tata et 30 et toyota ça
veut dire qu est-ce qui est la plus
importante au monde ou dans la création
et c'est l'être humain
il revient l'être humain en effet pour
se parler en effet pont essayer de se
comprendre d'aller vers l'autre bien sûr
on n'est peut-être pas seul on est très
petit quand on voit l'univers énorme
il y à une diversité infinie de cultures
de langues dans le monde peut-être plus
loin que le monde on sait pas encore on
peut bien se demander mais à quoi ça
peut servir de parler une langue
minorisée dans ce contexte là si on veut
communiquer si on veut se comprendre ne
serait-il mieux
de parler tout la même langue mais non
mais non parfois c'est difficile de
parler une langue étrangère je suis la
preuve est aussi il faut avouer que pour
chaque culture pour chaque façon de
penser pour chaque société culture ils
ont leur propre manière de parler et de
montrer leur histoire de raconter une
histoire qui est propre à eux et je
devrais dire histoire au pluriel aussi
parce que parfois la langue minorisée ou
n'importe quelle langue c'est la langue
naturelle pour la personne qui la parle
ce n'est pas pour des raisons politiques
c'est juste parce que c'est la langue
naturelle la citation la vienne d'un
porteur maori qui dit qu' il fait ça ils
parlent pas le maori juste pour faire
comme si mais il le fait parce que c'est
la manière dans l'univers prend voit en
lui
c'est une jolie manière de dire
maintenant quelque chose d'autre on va
regarder un peu le prendre des parts
quittant beaucoup de cas de beaucoup de
langues indigènes
il s'agit de parler de la terre ou d'un
lieu spécifique
maintenant on va se prêter à partir on
voyage on a le passeport près on voit
que dans les deux pays
nouvelle zélande irlande la langue
minorisée a quand même un statut
officiel et tous les documents officieux
ont quand même la version bilingue
maintenant pour notre voyage
on commence en irlande va se demander où
aller si j'ai remis 12 aller en irlande
il faut toujours se méfier un petit peu
des panneaux de signalisation c'est pas
toujours vrai vrai mais il al'avantage
d'être bilingue
alors comme ça vous pouvez pas vous
perdre maintenant on va faire un petit
pas vers la nouvelle zélande pour
montrer que même si la langue à un
statut officiel quelque chose que la
langue anglaise
n'a pas là bas dans la vie quotidienne
ça reste une langue un peu invisible
alors pour notre voyage on va essayer de
voir dans quelle manière une langue
minorisée peut devenir visibles ou dans
quelle manière quelqu'un qui vient dans
une société une communauté qui n'est pas
super bien représenté à l'échelle
nationale peut se réprésenter peut
s'exprimer et peut se faire comprendre
par d'autres personnes les noms
locuteurs par exemple notre voyage
commence comme vous fait pratiquement
tous les jours ceux d'entre vous qui
sont conducteurs
il faut toujours regarder dans le
rétroviseur avant d'avancer
avant de faire de prendre des virages et
j'ai trouvé que c'était une bonne image
pour parler de notre aventure culturelle
linguistique
parce que ça montre que même si on
avance
c'est toujours avec une idée du passé
qu'est ce qu'on vient de vivre
qu'est ce qu'on va vivre bientôt et
l'image est aussi intéressante parce que
ça montre que souvent ce convoi n'est
pas la réalité mais juste une réflexion
et peut-être que si une réflexion qu'on
voit à travers ou peut-être que comme
c'était le cas avec moi
le rétroviseur s'est cassé suite à une
manoeuvre pas bien réussi dans tous les
cas je veux dire que notre appréhension
dhr la réalité d'une culture d'une
langue souvent s'est traduit par un
écran par un miroir ou par par exemple
les médias etc
par rapport aux médias que j'aimerais
vous parler maintenant dans le contexte
des langues et les images des cultures
porté par ces langues
pendant très longtemps en irlande comme
en nouvelle zélande dans les communautés
irlando phone et mauri il y avait un
petit problème de représentation sur
l'écran surtout les grands écrans
cinématiques même les petits écrans de
télévision et le problème était la
suivante que les images qu'on voyait
n'était pas les images faites par le
public
c'était plutôt des images importées
l'application que vous voyez là sont les
propos d'un réalisateur irlande au fon
irlandais qui s'appelle chrono cofely
est pour lui le problème c'était qu'ils
avaient beaucoup des gens à l'extérieur
l'étranger qui nous regardait un peu
sous microscope
mais y avait jamais sur nos écrans ne te
prendre vu pour regarder le monde ou
avoir un regard vers l'extérieur alors
pour essayer de combler ce manque et
avec l'évolution de la technologie
numérique
ça a beaucoup avancé mais déjà il ya vu
des premiers pas pris part à pardon
d'abord je voulais vous montrer quelques
exemples de ce problème là alors mes
exemples 100 à gauche pour l'irlande
c'est une vision assez américaine d'une
partie de l'histoire irlandaise et à
droite on voit depuis ian e si un film
qui est ce n'est pas un film
hollywoodien mais ça reste quand même un
film avec un père une perspective
comment dire blanche une perspective pas
maori qui montre les personnages maori
la culture marie un peu comme toile de
fond exotiques dans le film fenouil qui
parle un peu de l'immigration irlandaise
suite à la grande famine milieu du 19e
siècle qui a d'ailleurs provoqué la
perte de la langue en grand partie
ici on voit il ya tom cruise et nicole
kidman qui vont jouer les les rôles
principaux qui sort essentielle
irlandais je peux vous dire que leur
accent n'était pas au rendez vous mais
moi je peux rien dire parce que je sais
que mon accent français n'est pas je ne
fais pas semblant d'être française c'est
à dire que pendant longtemps aussi deux
films la vienne des années 90 mais bien
avant il y avait aussi des problèmes de
réprésentation par les gens d'extérieur
et les gens à l'intérieur ne fait pas
souvent les moyens pour se représenter
tout ça commençait à changer les années
70 parce qu'il y avait un peu accès un
peu plus facile à la technologie des
caméras pour les gens qui parlaient les
langues minorisées alors on voit sur le
côté gauche
poutine un film de pop queen en irlande
c'est un film qui au lieu de montrer les
beaux paysages que je vous ai montré
tout à l'heure il montre des gens un peu
méchant enivré qui qui sent très bon
l'opposé de bons voisins
il joue un petit peu avec les
stéréotypes mais ça reste très très
local comme films comme vision c'est
vraiment sensé être pour les gens qui
vit qui vivent ce genre de vie ou qui
connaissent des voisins comme ça à
l'autre côté on voit marty c'est un des
premiers films
un des premiers longs métrages maori
partiellement langue anglaise mais fait
par un directeur maori paris barclay et
qu'ils pouvaient c'était le premier film
où paris par clic vraiment montrer ce
qui pouvait être une autre approche à la
production parce que ce n'est pas
seulement les images fine
le convoi sur l'écran mais aussi le
processus de production qui peut être
différente
je parle elle a vite fait des années 70
les années 80 et les années 2000 il y
avait quelque chose de très important
qui s'est passé c'est que après 30 ans
de lutte dans les deux pays et aussi un
parallèle assez inattendu mais très
bienvenus il y avait une chaîne de
télévision nationale créé pour diffuser
tout le pays en langues minorisées
nationale on voit tikal en irlande et
mauri tlv gêne pour la nouvelle-zélande
dans les deux cas ça a pris comme je
disais trois décennies de lutte parce
qu'il y avait beaucoup de gens même dans
le pays qu'ils étaient contre une fois
recommencée
les chaînes ont connu un succès énorme
parce que avec de plus en plus de
démissions importé des états unis et
d'angleterre parce qu'il s'agit des pays
anglophones mon l'itv triticale et il
est presque les seules chaînes qui
faisait vraiment beaucoup de production
sur place ou productions maison si vous
voulez ce sont pas les seules chaînes de
ce genre là dans le monde
et là c'est vraiment juste un petit
échantillon si je parle à la fois du
cinéma et de la télévision
c'est parce que dans l'est pour les
langues minorisées en fait l'évolution
des images publiques parce parler d'eux
le travail de bob queen et paris
paraclet au cinéma a montré à essayer a
réussi à convaincre les gens que c'est
ça valait la peine d'avoir une chaîne de
télévision
maintenant les chaînes de télévision
nous montre qu' il y à de nouveaux
talents qui arrive c'est un peu un
vivier pour créer d'autres films aux
courts métrages longs métrages
j'aimerais vous parler de barkly un
petit peu de petit peu plus de détails
il est mort maintenant mais j'ai eu le
privilège de le rencontrer quand j'étais
en nouvelle zélande j'y ai passé trois
ans pour pour mes études et une des
idées de bari barclays qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est l'idée de trop king et
nous trop king out c'est un peu le
parallèle de l'idée de kuurne confie
tout à l'heure l'idée de regard de
l'extérieur ou regard vers l'extérieur
ici paris paraclet ya l'idée que parfois
nous on fait des films en fait des
émissions avec l'idée que le public sera
des nôtres que le public va tout
comprendre
parfois on fait des films avec l'idée et
ça c'est l'idée de talking house que le
public va rien comprendre il faut tout
expliquer parfois avec des sous titres
parfois avec un personnage qui vient de
l'extérieur qui va des métiers en
pourquoi vous faites comme ça et l'autre
personnage veille tout expliquer et
rocking in c'est parce qu'on parle à
quelqu'un qu'on connaît qui connaît la
situation trop qu'inapte c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est destiné à un grand
public mondial
faut dire que la mondialisation n'est
pas quelques pas en soi quelque chose de
mauvais pour les langues minorisées
parce que comme j'utilisais avec le
numérique est l'axé maintenant on a la
possibilité d'atteindre un public
beaucoup plus vaste
suite et je vais pas entrer dans tous
les détails la suite aux idées de
barclays il y a des idées
les idées ont suscité louhans provoqué
chez les jeunes la nouvelle génération
de producteurs réalisateurs en nouvelle
zélande
ces six principes là qui montre comment
approcher une production d'une manière
différente
comment montrer du respect pour la
culture les traditions la langue et
comment mieux
faire en sorte que le public soit
impliqué dans le film il y a moins de
distinction entre réalisateurs
république quelqu'un tout le monde peut
participer si vous voulez je veux parler
de deux exemples avant de terminer un
exemple c'est le film de strings of
mother
je pense que c'est un film qui fait un
peu de trot king heen mais qui est quand
même compréhensible par un public
extérieur
ce film-là loup vous voyez il y à des
jeunes jumeaux frères et soeurs pendant
tout le film
il semble très complices vers la fin du
film on comprend qu'en fait la soeur est
morte et depuis la début mai le fond le
frère elle est toujours là pour le frère
il est toujours vivante
c'est un petit peu comme la langue
minorisée qu'ils n'aient pas vu pas
entendu par les autres mais les quand
même là et elle agit sur son
environnement
les différences entre ces films et
d'autres films européens par exemple qui
peut utiliser le même astuce c'est que
pour tous les personnages c'est tout à
fait normal qu'elle était morte et le
début et qu'on la voit quand même c'est
normal ça fait pas peur
ça fait partie de la vie l'autre exemple
que je voulais vous en parler c'est un
film irlandais qui s'appelle silence
ça montre un peu comment l'être humain
peut avoir un relation avec qui le
paysage dans lequel il se trouve
ici on voit les boues paysages vides der
land vide à cause de l'histoire et
l'histoire de silence c'est un preneur
de son qui va dans les endroits où il ya
personne pour essayer de prendre des
sons du silence
et c'est sur cela que j'aimerais
terminer si le silence que vous allez
voir
ana en effet le sens fort
un musée comment les gens
il dit au début et à la fin de toutes
les chansons il ya le silence
on peut parler parler parler on peut
chanter chanter chanter mais avant et
après il y a toujours le silence quand
une langue n'est plus parlée
on peut dire que c'est le silence quand
on voit plus d'image plus de
représentations plus d'expression d'une
langue d'une culture on peut dire que
c'est le silence
cela ne nous fait pas peur
on est entouré par le silence c'est
notre ambiance et notre environnement
on va jamais cessé d'essayer de
communiquer quand même on va jamais
cessé de créer des images de les montrer
de continuer à parler tout en respectant
le silence qui nous enveloppe comme il
marguet merci